por vergüenza,
por eso, bueno, diseñé la taza antiderrame.
Funciona gracias a su forma.
La curva superior desvía el líquido hacia adentro en cada temblor,
y eso mantiene el líquido dentro en contraste con una taza normal.
Lo importante aquí es que no es solo un producto para pacientes de Parkinson.
Parece una taza para ser usada por Uds., o yo, o cualquier persona torpe,
y eso la hace más cómoda de usar, y pasar desapercibida.
Bueno, un problema resuelto,
y mucho más por delante.
En todo este tiempo, lo entrevisté,
le pregunté,
y me di cuenta de que obtenía información muy superficial,
o solo respuestas a mis preguntas.
Pero tenía que profundizar para obtener una nueva perspectiva.
Y pensé, bueno, observémoslo en sus tareas cotidianas,
mientras come, mientras mira TV.
Y al observarlo caminar hacia su mesa del comedor,
me impactó que este hombre hallara dificultad al caminar en suelo plano,
¿cómo subir una escalera?
Porque en India no tenemos carriles estupendos para subir escaleras
como en los países desarrollados.
Uno tiene que subir las escaleras.
Así que me dijo:
"Bueno, te mostraré cómo lo hago".
Veamos lo que yo vi.
Demoró mucho en llegar a esta posición,
y en todo este tiempo, pienso,
"Dios mío, ¿realmente lo va a hacer?
¿Realmente lo va a hacer sin andador?"
Y luego...
(Risas)
Dio giros con mucha facilidad.
¿Impactados?
Bueno, yo también.
Esta persona que no podía caminar en suelo plano
de repente era un profesional subiendo escaleras.
Investigando, me di cuenta de que se debe a que es un movimiento continuo.
Este otro hombre tiene los mismos síntomas
y usa un andador,
pero cuando está en una bicicleta,
desaparecen sus síntomas,
porque es un movimiento continuo.
La clave para mí fue traducir esta sensación de caminar escaleras
al suelo plano.
En él, probamos muchas ideas,
pero la que finalmente funcionó fue esta. Veamos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Caminó más deprisa, ¿no?
Yo lo llamo la ilusión de la escalera,
y en realidad cuando acabó la ilusión de la escalera abruptamente, se congeló,
y esto se llama bloqueo de la marcha.
Sucede mucho,
de modo que ¿por qué no tener una ilusión de escalera en cada habitación,
para brindar mucha más confianza?
La tecnología no siempre lo es todo.
Necesitamos soluciones centradas en la persona.
Yo podía haber hecho una proyección
o usar Google Glass, o algo así.
Pero estaba limitada a impresiones en el piso.
Esta impresión podría llevarse a hospitales
para hacerlos sentir mucho más bienvenidos.
Deseo que cada paciente de Parkinson
se sienta como mi tío aquel día.
Él me dijo que le hice sentir que recuperaba su viejo yo otra vez.
"Smart" en el mundo actual es sinónimo de última tecnología,
y el mundo se vuelve cada vez más "smart".
Pero ¿por qué "smart" no puede ser algo simple y efectivo?
Solo necesitamos un poco de empatía y un poco de curiosidad,
salir y observar.
Pero no paremos allí.
Encontremos estos problemas complejos. No les temamos.
Dividámoslos, descompongamos eso en problemas mucho más pequeños,
y luego encontremos soluciones simples para ellos.
Probemos estas soluciones, fallemos si es necesario,
pero con ideas nuevas para hacerlo mejor.
Imaginen lo que podríamos hacer si todos aportáramos soluciones simples.
¿Cómo sería el mundo si combináramos todas nuestras soluciones simples?
Hagamos un mundo más inteligente, pero con simplicidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)